las instituciones financieras de la
segunda economía más grande del mundo se
preparan para lo peor nerviosos por el
posible impago de pasivos de más de 305
mil millones de dólares o el 2% del pib
chino los inversionistas del gigante
evergrande arrastraron el lunes las
acciones de hong kong a mínimos de un
año y el título del grupo a su nivel más
bajo en una década
a lo largo de los años lo que causa todo
esto es el apalancamiento excesivo de
sus operaciones comerciales eso
significa que obtuvieron más
financiamiento del que realmente podían
cubrir con fundado en 1996
este grupo de emplea a más de 200 mil
personas de manera directa y tiene
participación en otras industrias como
vehículos eléctricos y parques temáticos
también es dueño de gwangju fc uno de
los más grandes del país en su momento
su fundador su viaje llegó al ser el
hombre más rico del mundo según la
revista forbes pero sus problemas se
aceleraron este año a medida que las
nuevas viviendas perdieron valor y el
gobierno lanzó nuevas regulaciones para
el sector inmobiliario con el objetivo
declarado de combatir la especulación
una eventual falta de pago podría
generar riesgos más amplios para el
sistema financiero mundial los más
temerosos de wallstreet se atreven a
desempolvar lo sucedido en 2008 cuando
el colapso de un solo banco de inversión
originó la peor crisis económica en
décadas